una de las primeras cosas que hicimos
con números reales fue aprender a
sumarlos y arrestarlos así que vamos a
hacer lo mismo con números complejos
empecemos por la suma supongamos que
tengo el número complejo
que es igual a tres más dos y tres más
dos y
y también tengo el número complejo b que
va a ser igual a menos uno menos 3
esas son mis dos números complejos y
supongan sé que quiero definir un nuevo
número complejo sé que va a ser igual a
más
bien entonces los invito a pausar el
vídeo antes de que diga cómo se va a
hacer esto para que imaginen cómo podría
sumar estos números complejos pues
veamos a más vez sería lo mismo que tres
más dos y tres más dos y más b
- 1 - 3 y ahora bien yo sé que no puedo
sumar la parte real con la parte
imaginaria de un número complejo pero si
puedo sumar la parte real de a con la
parte real de b y la parte imaginaria de
a con la parte imaginaria de b y si hago
eso que obtengo pues si sumo tres con
menos 1 que sería la suma de las partes
reales no tendría 3 más menos 1 es 2
y si sumo 2
con -3 y pues podríamos pensar que
factor hizo la y me queda 23 que sería
menos 1 así que obtendrían menos 1 por
lo que es lo mismo 2 menos
ahora también puedo pensar en esto
gráficamente cómo le hago pues recurro a
lo que se llama un diagrama de garganta
me voy al plano complejo que recuerden
lo que es el plano cartesiano habitual
en donde el eje i va a ser mi eje
imaginario aquí voy a poner las
coordenadas imaginarias de mi número
complejo y mi eje x va a ser mi eje real
es decir aquí va la parte real de mi
número complejo entonces veamos como
dije esto se llama un diagrama de
garganta
diagrama
argán entonces lo que voy a hacer es
esencialmente pensar en el número
complejo a como un vector en este plano
cartesiano así que si tengo que a es
igual a 3 + 2 y geográfico veamos 1 2
3 me da la parte real y 2 para la parte
imaginaria 1 2
así que por aquí estaría el número
complejo y si lo piensa como un vector
se vería algo así
esto de aquí lo voy a pensar como mi
número complejo
y mi número complejo b
sería de nuevo otro vector menos uno
como a menos tres así que menos 1,1
23 b sería un vector bueno está un poco
mal b sería este vector de aquí
recuerden el principio de los vectores
siempre está en el origen ahora cómo
puedo sumar a ive pues esencialmente
como si fueran vectores normales lo
único que voy a hacer es tomar la cola
de ve y trasladarla a la punta de a si
hago eso entonces si copio a b y lo
trasladó lo muevo sin cambiar su
dirección hasta este punto a donde
llegaría pues de nuevo tengo que bajar 3
y moverme 1 a la izquierda así que
uy
bajar 3 y moverme 1 a la izquierda más o
menos
eso se supone que debería ser paralelo
así que esta es una copia debe por así
decirlo y entonces tienes además ve pues
el vector resultante va a ser este
vector de aquí
este vector que une al origen con la
punta terminal de la copia debe esto de
aquí sería ce y noten que tiene sentido
porque realmente lo que hice fue pensar
en la parte real la parte imaginaria
como los componentes de un vector sumar
la parte horizontal sumar el 3 con el
menos 1 y obtengo 2 y después sumar la
parte vertical que corresponde a la
parte imaginaria 2 + menos 3 que sería
menos 1 y obtengo este vector de aquí
así que la suma la suma de números
complejos definida de este modo es
completamente análoga a la suma de
vectores de los diagramas de arganda